c'è un compleanno se qualcuno ride ci
vediamo nel 2039 mi fate vedere i vostri
capelli al compimento del
sessantacinquesimo anno di età
diventiamo ufficialmente degli anziani
stando alla definizione attuale
facendo due calcoli io sono del 74 fine
74 quindi in questo periodo tra
vent'anni
dovrei compiere 65 anni quindi stando
alla definizione attuale dove diventare
un anziano o forse come è meglio dire o
preferisco dire un diversamente giovane
quello che cercheremo di fare nei
prossimi minuti di immaginarci assieme
come si potrebbe svolgere la giornata al
mio 65esimo compleanno questo è quello
che cercherò di fare con voi
sono le sette del mattino è il mio
assistente virtuale che si chiama ulisse
che poi è un simpatico ben con sé un
intelligente automa con un ologramma
decide di farmi una sorpresa modo suo
compleanno quindi disattiva la sveglia e
trasforma la mia camera da letto quando
io mi sveglio in un ambiente
meraviglioso proietta ad altissima
risoluzione sulle pareti sul pavimento e
sul soffitto le scene una delle scene
che io amo di più una scena una scena
del mare della mia spiaggia preferita e
in più arriva anche il suo arriva anche
l'odore perché tutto viene trasmesso in
7 g 6 c era una tecnologia del passato
ogni 10 anni più o meno abbiamo cambiato
adesso sono arrivati al 7 g insomma la
giornata non potrebbe cominciare meglio
nel migliore dei modi
in più il buon ulisse si affianca a me
il solo gramma e mi dice che sa che non
ho avuto una buona notte a causa della
mia cena abbondante della sera prima e
apprezzo il tocco di di umano tatto non
mi dice eccessiva mamma abbondante
effettivamente la mia stanza piena di
sensori la mia casa è piena di sensori
che riescono a valutare il mio il mio
stato
i parametri d'italia quindi
effettivamente uri sarà giocano non ho
avuto certo una buona notte e ulisse
prepara tutto a cura di me e ha già
preparato la colazione è tutto pronto
nello schermo del frigorifero mi dà dei
suggerimenti per un po di l'ipertensione
quindi mi ricorda sempre cosa cosa cosa
è più opportuno che mangi oggi e quando
li segue a tavola utilizzo delle posate
che sono delle posate intelligenti
analizzano il mio microbioma cioè
l'insieme degli organismi i
microorganismi dentro linee inviano
tutto in tempo reale sulla piattaforma
del mio medico curante anche lì in
streaming
e su questo affluisce anche tutta tutta
l'insieme di tutto l'insieme dei dati
che vengono dai miei sensori dalla mia
stanza dei sensori ambientali e in più
stamattina anche parlato con la gente
del mio medico la gente virtuale del mio
medico che gli ha consigliato la
posologia che poi verrà emessa dal mio
smartphone durante la giornata proprio
permettere a bada la mia la mia
ipertensione e più tardi nella giornata
alle otto e trenta è ora di lavorare sì
perché si lavora si continua a lavorare
alla vita pensionabile come voi ben
sapete ormai è stata spostata più in
avanti e le politiche sociale dei primi
anni 20 30
nel 2003 vi ricordate
hanno finalmente rivalutato l'importanza
di noi con i capelli bianchi quindi il
nostro ruolo è decisamente amplificato
adesso ci sono in piena forza dal punto
di vista cognitivo dal punto di vista
fisico riesco ancora a contribuire in
più l'intelligenza artificiale la
robotica quello che si chiama internet
of jobs l'internet dei lavori hanno
rivoluzionato il mondo della vora non è
più come negli anni venti e quello che
succede che adesso la maggior parte dei
lavori viene fatto in remoto di ulisse
che negozi ai miei lavori i miei
incarichi di lavoro per per tante per
tante aziende contemporaneamente e non
vengo scelto soltanto per le mie
competenze che lo posso fare anche il
robot le marche ma soprattutto per per
gli aspetti che sono più umani per
esempio per la mia simpatia o per le mie
capacità sociali o relazionali ed ev
disse che gestisce i miei carichi di
lavoro lasciandomi anche un po di tempo
libero
ulisse e mi accompagna durante la
giornata lavorativa perché mi fa anche
da assistente e oggi ho deciso di
lavorare da casa di resta il mio è il
mio compleanno ma in più ormai è normale
potere lavorare in remoto e la mia
giornata è che poi a casa che il mio
ufficio si svolge con ulisse che
gestisce minuto per minuto la
temperatura la ventilazione l'umidità
per far sì che il mio livello di stress
sia basso che io lavori al meglio e ogni
tanto semisecco male visto che ci sono
dei sensori che meritano anche il mio la
mia postura mi tira le orecchie mi
ricorda che mi devo mi devo sapere in
maniera in maniera più opportuna in più
o degli strumenti nuovi o delle lenti a
contatto che non soltanto tracciano il
punto di vista quindi che riescono a
capire dove sto guardando
e ovviamente correggono il mio debole
deficit visivo ma in più proiettano sul
mio occhio delle informazioni che mi
possono essere utili e mi aiutano
l'utilizzo come gli schermi di una volta
del telefono vi ricordate che una volta
c'era il cellulare e tutte le
informazioni vengono presentati davanti
agli occhi e ulisse quando sono stanco
ingrandisce il contenuto digitale con
cui con cui interagisco mi fa da memoria
aumentata lui mi ricorda mi aiuta a
ricordare le informazioni di fatto
dandomi dei superpoteri quasi e in più
un altro apparecchio un apparecchio di
tipo che viene utilizzato non lo vedrete
vi aiuta a sentire meglio ma in più
elimina anche i rumori mi fa dormire
meglio in questo modo riesco a
concentrarmi meglio quando lavoro in più
queste le cuffie tu il vivavoce adesso
non ci sono più ovviamente e o il grande
vantaggio che questi sensori impiantati
non devo più ricaricarle loro raccolgono
l'energia dal mio corpo produco calore
mi muovo faccio produca energia fanno
quello che si chiama inglese energy
harvesting e quindi non devono anche più
ricaricarli sono con me e neanche me ne
accorgo la
giornata è finita finisce presto
aggiornato ad attiva grazie al cielo
posso lavorare un po di meno preso anche
molto molto efficiente e deciso di
passare alla seconda parte della mia
giornata con i miei genitori perché sono
ancora vivi anno 91 e 99 anni e fanno
parte di quel milione e mezzo milione 6
di italiani ultra novantenni ed è una
bella fetta della popolazione devono
vivere in autonomia a casa da soli e
decido di videochiamarli ovviamente
utilizzo degli eventi a contatto per
vedere e per comunicare utilizzo il mio
impianto e la videochiamata gli viene
automaticamente ri diretta dal loro
agente l'equivalente del miu miu ulisse
accanto a loro tavolo il mignolo gramma
riesco a comunicare parliamo lo sono di
soggiorno che chiacchierano
tranquillamente e ci mettiamo d'accordo
poi per la seconda parte della giornata
per la serata che passeremo insieme li
andrò a prendere e quello che vi vorrei
raccontare la casa i miei genitori
adesso ovviamente è stata ben attrezzata
hanno sensori ovunque non soltanto
trasmettono i parametri vitali ma
riescono anche a comprendere come si
stanno muovendo tutte queste
informazioni vanno inviate e
continuamente sulla piattaforma del
medico curante che non analizza più è
uno a uno i dossier dei pazienti ci
mancherebbe altro
troppa sono troppi dati però viene
informato nel momento in cui c'è un
problema un problema rilevante
ad esempio se c'è un cambiamento dei
parametri vitali importante vengo
notificato anch'io ovviamente con con il
loro consenso
oppure se c'è una caduta elemento
drammatico oppure se uno dei due per
esempio comincia a muoversi la notte per
fare wondering che è un segno di click
chiaro del
dell'alzheimer cioè camminare la notte
in maniera come dire scoordinata e la
vita dei miei genitori trascorrere
serenamente a casa in autonomia e oltre
all'assistente virtuale hanno anche
bisogno di un assistente fisico che loro
chiamano oscar
mi ricordo i primi anni 2020 2030 in
questo un grande dibattito etico sul
sull'opportunità di adottare robot a
casa degli anziani si oggetti ficano gli
anziani invece no sono diventate un
pezzo fondamentale della società della
vita degli anziani e hanno cura di loro
li coccolano fanno come comunicano
quindi eliminano l'isolamento sociale li
accudiscono fanno i compiti di casa
fanno la spesa e contribuiscono a
ridurre l'isolamento 6 fano star meglio
adesso sono totalmente totalmente a
cesate accettati mentre vi racconto
tutto questo il buon ulisse ha prenotato
un servizio di taxi che per andare a
prendere i miei genitori e come ben
sapete ormai le auto sono tutte a guida
automatica
solo che questo un servizio speciale è
un taxi dove c'è dentro una persona ma
la persona non guida la persona arriva e
aiuta ad anziano a salire in auto
fa quel gli ultimi 50 metri i primi 50
metri se volete del tragitto dove
necessariamente ancora c'è bisogno di
qualcuno che aiuti potrebbe essere anche
un robot e questo è uno degli esempi di
servizi innovativi che sono nati proprio
per rispondere ai bisogni di una
popolazione che sta cambiando
profondamente ormai profondamente
cambiata il
taxi arriva puntuale ci incontriamo
tutti all'angolo del parco e cominciamo
la nostra passeggiata mentre camminiamo
mi arriva una segnalazione sulle mie
lenti a contatto che mi occupassi saldi
ritardando ovviamente questo è segnalato
per lui ha addosso dei i suoi vestiti
hanno dei sensori che trasmettono i suoi
dati e come vi dicevo con un consenso
suo io so che si sta diradando piuttosto
che fermarci decidiamo di continuare
andare al ristorante tanto che ormai li
a pochi metri dove ci aspetta la
famiglia e gli amici
la nostra famiglia è una famiglia
particolare si chiama bimbo and family
in inglese spilungona è stretta e alta
di fatto ci sono ormai in quasi tutte le
famiglie 45 generazioni ma è poco larga
perché non ci sono più bimbi e arriva è
arrivata anche memorie che anche nei
lavora giustamente e c'è mia figlia con
con il suo bimbo la il suo compagno è
mio figlio non c'è perché all'estero
però lui si collega in telepresenza
tanto ormai ormai è facile
come tutte le feste di compleanno e
adesso è il momento del regalo e mi
viene consegnato la busta io la apro e
vedo che c'è un biglietto per una
crociera per due per me e per mia moglie
una crociera io adoro il mare ma
realizzo che una crociera per anziani è
una crociera fatta apposta per gente
anziana e proprio in questo momento io
realizzo che sono ai 65 anni e quindi
fino a qualche anno fa
io sarei stato considerato un anziana un
vecchio se preferite è errata adesso
sono nel pieno delle mie forze e
comincio a pensare faccio una
riflessione se guardo indietro e guardo
come era la società nel 1959 per ogni
anziano c'erano grosso modo tre bimbi
tre giovani e poco più che oggi nel 2039
la situazione è completamente diversa ci
ritroviamo che quel solo bimbo deve
tenere il peso di due e più anziani e
riflette un attimo e dico che noi
anziani o diversamente giovani se
preferite abbiamo una responsabilità
enorme
dobbiamo prenderci gran cura di noi
stessi
utilizzare tutti i mezzi tecnologici e
che la medicina ci offre per fare in
modo che noi stiamo bene viviamo in
autonomia a casa e per fare in modo che
il peso sulle spalle di quel bimbo non
diventi insopportabile
grazie a tutti
[Applauso]